I feel like if I'm addicted to any drug
my drug of choice is being late I know
you can't smoke it I know you can't
snort it but being late is a drug it's
like an amphetamine it's like a
stimulant think about it if you would to
be at work at 9:00 and you wake up at
9:30 Woo you're up holy hell you look
like a drug addict your eyes are popped
you're sweat in your drive work I'm
super late I'm super late I'm super late
I'm super late yeah you get to work it's
like you're coked up you're talking
about I'm so sorry I hate myself I'm gay
I love
you I've lost jobs relationships friends
hate me now you know and I don't know
every time I'm late it's like I've done
a drug I'm like I'll never do that again
I feel like hell of a horrible person
and then a week later woo I'm late all
over again I'm back off the wagon and
it's actually worse than a drugs it's
free it's legal and there's no cure for
it yeah even if your friends and family
get together like Mark's always late we
got to have an intervention by the time
I show up they're
gone